hi Carmichael and welcome to another
edition of ask Evan in today's video I'm
going to answer questions from what a
reader Shauna who wrote it i'm going to
read your email we do a lot of
recruiting for work at home positions
during our peak seasons from if i were
to july our work at home agents act as
if they were within our on-site call
centers taking calls in queue to book
camping reservations we had a real big
problem with retention last season any
tips we can use some the recruiting
standpoint to help prevent this from
occurring next year we lost many of our
agents within the first month of
employment Thank You Shauna so Shauna
it's very common here a couple of ideas
that might help you get over that hump
and make sure that you have the right
people coming on board step number one
is make sure you have the right person
at the start right so what I would do is
start profiling the top people you've
had in the past who have worked out
really well look at the personality
types of it their situation and see what
common threads there are so when you're
looking for new people it's easier to
pick out the ones that are going to be
the winners you might even consider
having some of those people who've done
really well for you in the past help you
hire some of the new people because
you're basically looking for people like
them right your top performers you want
to get them involved you want to hire
more top performers and if they're
involved in the process they might be
able to help you find other people who
are similar you might also even ask them
if they have any people they can
recommend right up the hard working and
doing a good job they might know other
people who are working and could also do
a pinch a good job for you as well and
refer some of their friends so that may
be another strategy to get people in the
door in terms of getting people to stay
and getting them engaged and wanted them
to continue on with your company I
really look at your training and see if
people are set up to win so how much
training do you do at the beginning how
much do you show that you really care
about
and how much do you show that what
they're doing really ties into the
bigger picture and they're helping a lot
of people people will often leave
because they don't feel like they're
adding a lot of value are they're not
really having fun with their position so
if you could train that and show them
how they can start winning and getting
those early hits quickly the more likely
to want to stay the last thing you might
want to consider is create a mentorship
program and i know this is only a part
time position but hopefully could be
something that people can come back to
year after year if you are consistently
you know hooking up and you need to have
these positions filled if you can
connect the new workers with people who
have already been doing it for a couple
years a little bit more seasoned that
they have any questions you can connect
them so they're not always in with you
who might be the owner of the business
and there might be a little more
formality or people a little bit more
worried about doing or saying the wrong
thing but if you can connect them with
what if your other work at home wages
has done a good job before to be able to
answer any more personal questions that
might help them that could be a good
step to making them want to stay on
board and it's also a good development
opportunity for your more senior agents
who've been doing it for a while and
makes them feel like they're growing the
business too I'm not just doing the same
thing over and over and over again so
you're providing more opportunity for
learning development than they had
before so time isn't even more closely
to the business that want to help out
with even more so I hope that helps if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below and I'd also love to
hear thoughts and feedback if you want
to leave a comment below the video and
stay tuned to the next episode
you
you